my BSF that shared to speak with me for
the last 15 years I'm honored to call
her my on and off screen bad ass friend
that whether it's for Hannah or Miley is
always right there when I need her
it's the reunion of the decade at least
according to Miley Cyrus yes fans got
the best of both worlds when Emily
Osment joined Miley for her bright mind
and Instagram live talk show on Monday
that was some stress
I was completely stressed the reunion
didn't go up easy though as fans eagerly
awaited and that's because the former
co-stars had a little trouble finding a
connection so today's some tech
difficulties but the sign is on and
poppin so that's all that we need to
know their bright minded episode was
puppy focus and Miley credited Emily as
being the brains behind the bright idea
and I actually was writing down that it
was totally your idea to spotlight
animal care at this time of her genius
idea the two have always shared a common
love of dogs something that Miley
highlighted when she decided to go down
Hannah Montana memory lane name of the
day where we gotta just take pictures of
the puppy oh man that was for a was that
Marie Claire or some sort of
Tebow oh I know she could see nothing
she did the show she didn't want your
hand or my hands to wrap around each
other for some reason so right so if you
put your hand back yeah with us focused
and we kept being like guys we're not
going to fall like what the hell well
little did you know we then just gave us
some puppies make it shut up and do it
they want it yeah which worked
Miley showed off some more throwback
pics this one ironically perfect for the
time this is Lola sanitizing Hannah Oh
perfect which there's a Latino a theory
that Hannah
so predicted everything that was ever
gonna happen in life Miley also pulled
out a old photo of the two on the day
their friendship began I remember the
day being like much longer than anyone
warned us it would be and I was like 12
costume changes and we all had to take a
lot of photos like that that was kind of
years longer than we thought
longer than we were warned now there is
a personal secret behind this picture
something you probably never would have
guessed this was our first day of press
and Mikey I've pretty much all decided
to fall out I look like I'm choking you
look I'm like going through they're
going for the throat yeah permission but
I look at that sweater vest Lybia my mom
thank you no that's definitely that's an
Ann Taylor top on me well apparently Dan
Taylor tops the youngest child ever
rockin Taylor oh yeah thanks mom one of
the best parts of this virtual reunion
was that it happened one day before the
13th anniversary of the Hannah Montana
premiere I talk about perfect timing I
want to say thank you so much your music
is better thank you for what you do with
animals
thanks for bringing up the idea to make
sure we highlight animal care at this
time and Lily last you the bass good to
see ya later and that's our show
[Music]